euh comment se règlent les transactionsi
ma question c'est toujours comment
est-ce que vous faites payer est-ce
qu'on paye avant est-ce qu'on paye après
c'est toujours un sujet parce qu'il ne
connaissent pas ils sont obligés de
gagner de nouveaux marchés donc bah des
fois ils prennent des risques financiers
très forts euh et donc soit ils disent
euh tu tu nous payes d'abord et on te
livre après bon mais ça marche pas
toujours euh ou alors ils font confiance
et ils prennent le risque de ne pas être
payé euh sachant que eux sont quand même
à des milliers de kilomètres donc c'est
toujours c'était toujours compliqué
aujourd'hui ils ont une solution magique
qui s'appelle le Bitcoin ils se font
payer pour beaucoup hein euh de clans du
cartel non pas par leurs clients
américains mais pour leurs clients par
leurs clients européens c'estàdire les
clients sur lesquel ils ont une emprise
assez faible en cas d'impayé ils sont
payés en cryptoonnaie et je ne dis pas
que le le le Bitcoin euh est un outil
inventé euh pour des pour pour le
blanchiment d'argent je dis absolument
pas ça la vocation de Bitcoin elle est
magnifique hein mais le blockchain qui
garantit finalement l'anonymat d'un
détenteur de Wallet d'un portefeuille de
Bitcoin c'est évidemment extrêmement
attractif pour ces gens-là euh ils ont
une question question quand même qui est
de le blanchiment après c'est-à-dire que
on peut être payé en Bitcoin mais si on
veut utiliser son argent en monnaie Fiat
il va bien falloir le convertir et à ce
momentl évidemment vous allez attirer
l'attention du banquier mais toujours
est-il que oui pour cet usage du
numérique en tout cas le seul point sur
lequel je je peux je je pense pour être
informant c'est effectivement les narcos
en tout cas ceux que je vois y compris
les Brésiliens utilisent massivement les
cryptos dernier point le blanchiment sur
les techniques de blanchiment elles sont
connues je sais que vous avez audité ici
des gens auditionné ici des gens
autrement plus plus autorisés encore une
fois mais ils blanchissent de façon
classique par injection du cash dans la
trésorerie de commerce avec qui ils ont
des partenariats ou qu'il possède
évidemment en utilisation ça c'est un
vrai sujet dans parmi les professions
assugjéties euh j'ai entendu hein ici
des banques très trèsès très critiqué
sans doute à raison parfois c'est le
tras peut-être un peu forcé les banques
dans certains pays elles font face à un
tsunami d'argent sale donc elles font ce
qu'elles peuvent mais elles sont elles
se mettent en conformité évidemment avec
les lois et les les directives mais il y
a je pense un acteur qui est est
massivement utilisé que sont les bureaux
de change les bureaux de change et
surtout dans leur dans leur vocation de
transfert de fonds de cash vers des
comptes en banques sont très très
utilisés par les narcos et ça je pense
que ils sont assujettis aux mêmes loi
que les banques je doute euh de la
vélocité de ces entreprises à mettre en
place euh ce que les banques ont mis en
place et puis surtout surtout surtout
dans le blanchiment utilisé les les
techniques de blanchiment utilisées par
ces grandes organisations criminelles je
parle pas des autres mais les grandes
organisations criminelles elles doivent
blanchir des dizaines de milliards de
dollars et pour ça il y a pas 50
solutions il faut utiliser des paradis
bancaires c'est-à-dire des États
qui sont censés réagir mais ne
réagissent quasiment pas lorsqu'une
demande de coopération judiciaire leur
est faite et ne transmettent aucune
information sur les données bancaires de
criminels recherché par des états-tiers
je pense notamment à Dubaï où j'ai
assisté à un entretien entre un
narcotrafiquant du cartel de Sinaloa et
une soci siété fiduciaire dont des
cadres lui expliquer j'ai enregistré
cette cet entretien encore une fois j'en
ai fait une partie d'un documentaire qui
est publique sur le monde et ce que ce
que disent ces cadres de la société
fiduciaire est parfaitement légal ils ne
commettent aucune infraction à Dubaï en
expliquant un ararco Mexicain dont ils
ne connaissent même pas le nom comment
blanchir via l'immobilier à Dubaï pour
conclure s'il est une action à mon avis
qui doit être conduite en matière
d'action
publique
certes elle doit avoir un volet
judiciaire mais aussi diplomatique le
plus dynamique qu'il
soit il n'y aura pas de ralentissement
de business illégaux qui chiffre à 2400
ou 6000% de marge tant qu'on ne touchera
pas le couteau suisse qui permet à ces
gens de blanchir ces gens vendent de la
drogue non par plaisir mais par à du
gain s'il est devenu difficile pour eux
de blanchir c'est-à-dire d'utiliser leur
argent ils seront ils seront moins
tentés de le faire et l'outil qui leur
permet de blanchir ce sont les paradis
bancaires au premier rang desquels Dubaï
je vais pas m'étendre sur ces raisons
mais c'est lié à l'importance de
l'immobilier à Dubaï et l'action
publique à mon avis elle doit aussi
porter sur des pressions sur ces trous
noirs de la finance mondiale les États
de l'Union européenne le Royaume-Uni
comme comme le les États-Unis ont été
capables d'appliquer en un temps record
des sanctions contre un état autrement
plus puissant les paradis bancaires la
Russie pourquoi ne le fait-on pas sur
ces paradis bancaires ce serait à mon
avis réduire à la
les problèmes auxquels aujourd'hui la
France fait face en matière de
narcotrafic